what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a clip
from kevin samuels modern women and war
for the dawn before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bow that way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos while you're at it go
follow my instagram
it's just pearly things but with instead
of an s
it's a z so go follow it because
i don't really like talking to women in
relationships with me because
i don't want to overstep boundaries of
guys appreciate you coming in i'm gonna
bring the rest of you guys in
i'ma say that again though ladies
gentlemen it is our job to customize the
women to us
it is your job to come in the door with
a can-do spirit
i need you to mop wash dishes
and sort lettuce don't tell me you want
to learn how to work the cash register
and be in drive-thru because that's
where the people
are i need you to mop wash dishes i mean
mop do the dishes and sort lettuce
don't tell me you want to i want to get
i want to go out in the dining room and
pass out fries
i think that if you have a good husband
who knows what you're good at and what
you're interested in i think he'll
help you pick accordingly i think
there's some things that women just
should do in a marriage like for example
cook um
and you know i mean some guys can cook
really well so it's not a hundred
percent but just in general
but yeah i think it's definitely like
you're supposed to play to each other's
strengths mop lettuce
dishes
is there a problem with that denise
apparently there's not a problem can you
hear me sir hello
oh no i don't know why i have a feeling
she's going to be crazy eyes i just got
a feeling
i can hear you now hold on how old are
you ah
lord i hope i don't get dragged for this
but i'm 37 i turned 37 in march of this
year
no dragon just asking just for
clarification so
modern women winter's coming what do we
got
so for me sir i feel like i agree with
everything you say
like i appreciate your transparency your
honesty
they give it to you straight no feeling
no chaser i want to say thank you um for
me
i am open to a relationship and i feel
like i have a good understanding of my
own emotional intelligence
and what i want okay and the role and
the dynamics between men and women and
i'm
fine with sharing power transferring
power
making it a true partnership but i got
an unusual i got some unusual
circumstances so i'm 37
okay i am an executive in a startup
i went to grad school i am also six five
six five oh my gosh that's impossible
she's gonna die alone i'm sorry i'm six
foot
do you know how much harder dating is
when you're six foot
because you're not necessarily attracted
to the guy shorter than you
like you know i mean sometimes but
it's it's rare so it really only leaves
guys your hider taller
right six five oh lord phd
i like to consider myself an in-shaped
person
very opinionated when i know when to
listen
and i mean i've been in relationships
that usually average about three to four
years and then i'll take a three to four
year break in between
but i would love to hear you speak on
the importance of not being
comfortable in being alone and in your
season of separation from a partner
because i feel like
i have gotten into a pattern that makes
it
difficult for me on top of everything
that i'm already
facing to meet a partner like i don't
you have any children some other man do
you have any children i'm sorry what was
that sir
do you have any children i do not and i
don't want them
he can come with children this uterus is
closed
how are you again 37.
okay well one of them one of the major
reasons men tend to want women as
children so you cut yourself out of a
large swapping man
because for me so okay okay
i have my questions okay
she's got crazy eyes a little bit uh
take away your job and who are you
i'm a friend i'm a loyal person i'm a
creative i'm a connector
i'm an advocate for other people i'm a
resource i'm a support system i'm
someone that can see
into your soul and i want you to eat and
love on you well
and meet you where you are what i would
say
what do you think what is your connector
okay friend sister
so do you have any brothers i'm an only
child
your last relationship was when five and
a half years ago
how long did it last four and a half
years
why didn't you guys why didn't he marry
his friend resource connector
i broke up the relationship myself he
wouldn't
always end the relationships i wonder
why
do you guys think that relationships can
genuinely be mutual let me know in the
comments
20 he was mid-20s i was late 20s early
30s and i felt like i was his mother in
situations and that's what happened when
you did a little bit
differently hold on no no that's what
happens when you go after somebody
that you can dominate
so i i broke it off because it didn't
feel right
i didn't feel like i was with a man i
didn't want to force him to be somewhere
he wasn't first of all you didn't pick
me first off you weren't chosen by a man
damn damn
he calls us out he calls us out
[Music]
you're 100 right so how do i position
myself to be chosen is it making myself
put your dick up available
oh what happened oh your dick
up oh dear
okay where's the lie you came here to
talk about i'm i'm i'm i'm
this i'm that and i all right sick i'm i
i i'm
my season of time you're really good at
telling women
what sounds like you know what you're
talking about
the training relationship for five years
and the last one you were with was with
a boy
oh okay
you're coming in he humbles he humbles
women
me on the other hand i'm humbled every
day by the internet man you want what
you want marriage
i do why
i would love to be able to spend the
rest of my life with someone
that loves me as much as i love them
that compliments me
that's my support system that i can lead
be led by learn from go through
challenging and exciting life
experiences with
i've done i've done me for a while i'm
kind of over it we could try something
new
it sounds like a brochure for a vacation
what happened not like a brochure for a
vacation i want somebody
do men want companionship um
because people get remarried when
they're older and a lot of times like
the guys and the girls they're too old
to have kids
um like for example my uncle just got
remarried and
the wife's 50 he's i don't know maybe 55
and clearly they're not gonna have any
more kids
i can lead be led by
challenging this and that sounds like a
brochure for a vacation
well i'm sorry i'm a communications man
i'm sorry that's that but what i'm
saying is
is i'm not hearing anything about a wife
i heard a sales pitch
nothing and when you talked you talk
about a partner
have you ever served a man define
serve for me have you ever gone to a
restaurant
i have what they what they do when they
um i'm gonna see when he answers the
questions if i've done that i come to
your table it's called what
service i have served a man on plenty
occasions
in your relationship i've cut right
right
could serve
typically i'm an active service person
that's one of my
me too queen me too crazy queen
the queen of languages oh my gosh fear
hates
women when women say that
i'm gonna get roasted automatically it's
me
so in your last relationship you served
a younger man
um i did and then i had like a brief
couple of months before coved really
took off
situation with someone where i served
him on multiple occasions
and he proved not to be worthy of said
service because he didn't
appreciate it his son appreciated it
more than he did
some of the things you did to serve your
boyfriend was what
give me about three things that you did
that you would do consistently
do consistently making meals making sure
i used to cook for my ex-boyfriend
store that when he was in my space he
was comfortable didn't
have to get i did his laundry all the
time
something to drink give you a pillow
give you a blanket what do you need
you clear your plate i can take that
away for you
one of my favorite dates that i had was
he brought over his son which made me
nervous i just met his
younger man the younger guy no this was
the guy that i dated briefly no i asked
you everybody i said
no no that's not who i asked about i
asked about your
long relationship okay so i would still
i would bring him food you know make
sure that he's comfortable in my space
make sure that he felt comfortable
didn't have to necessarily
ask or get up for anything because i
don't mind that especially if i have to
go get something for myself and make
sure you're taken care of
okay but making meals and making it an
experience because i'm a huge foodie so
i like
all right all right man you cooked okay
you cooked you don't have to
we don't have to you have to go into war
and peace about you making a meal
okay i make meals make sure that he was
taken care of if he had clothes over my
place that he had a spot
in my physical location if i'm gonna do
my lingerie and your laundry is at my
house i'm gonna do it as well
okay if i'm out and about and i see
something that makes me think of you i'm
not
opposed to bringing that home and doing
something nice
and it was reciprocated what does that
mean
gifts that means gifts i
surprised my boyfriend with gifts before
i've done that so yeah i'm just trying
to see if i've done it
i'm like because sometimes when you ask
the girls these questions i ask myself
these questions and he would like what
does that mean
like if i see a book that i know he's
interested in or if i see a bottle of
water
you were going together for four years
uh-huh
what'd you buy for his birthday i got
him an experience this one got scuba
diving
i i okay he took him scuba diving okay
no i bought him a certified i can't
swallow
him i bought him a certification to be
scuba dived
or certified in scuba diving i'm sorry
i've been having a glass of wine
what'd you buy where'd you get them for
christmas ah we didn't do christmas
the last year we'd get we're together we
didn't do christmas
livestreams we were there for four years
there were four christmases
well we just happened tonight get gifts
that year i don't know what the reason
i remember what the reasoning was he
just lost four years no christmas gifts
no we had other things you know okay all
right all right four years
four years no christmas four years no
christmas gifts
uh-huh so um
and you took him on scuba diving did he
ask do you want to go scuba diving
did he want to go did he want to go
scuba diving yeah he loves sea world
okay the water loves
i shouldn't have to raise my voice to
you i've done that several times and you
just keep talking
so all right no christmas gifts fine
scuba diving for a birthday what'd you
do the other three birthdays
had a beach had a beach trip went to new
orleans once
you paid for a beach trip i did not pay
we split
no that so you didn't know i said for
him for his birthday
we took a vacation we had no no what did
you do for him for his birthday
we went on a vacation that we okay
okay see you're already showing that you
don't even have any concept with what
i'm talking about
all you today i did was you cook so
cause you got to eat
that's that and you had him he had a
space in your house
like he's a pet damn
i'm asking you what did you really do
he's trying to think if we did
christmas oh i got
him yeah we did christmas what did you
really
gentlemen i've told you look at where a
woman puts her money and that's the
truth this woman didn't spend any money
on this man
because she really didn't care she spent
more money on her hair than she did on
him
that's why she can't answer the
questions
and you talk about you want to be
married why you don't want to have any
kids and you haven't said anything about
what a man is going to get other than a
bunch of words
that's so true because my
ex i would buy him gifts that genuinely
i could not afford
all the time i'm not all the time but
every like couple months
oh my gosh that's so true look at where
people put their money
this is where you could speak now okay
that's what i thought nothing to say you
got a phd no i don't know
it's just i guess i attract
what my behavior demonstrates and
attract what you want and
you attract what you are we all do
and everything okay so i agree with that
you attract what you are like clearly
the people you attract
have traits um
you know that's similar that are similar
to you but i had a question
that someone brought up to me when i
said this i said you attract what you
are
and this person said no you attract what
you allow because
you if you if someone cheats on you that
doesn't mean you're a cheater if you
didn't cheat
so how do you attract what you are and
that was a point that i didn't think of
so let me know in the comments
what you guys think of that everything
that you've talked about
is something about a picture but i ask
if i'm trying to get to who you are in a
relationship
and you talk about it but i got to the
substance
what you do really isn't further into
you
i bet if i asked him how you explain i i
asked him how he experienced you
you probably would be surprised
we had some very candid conversations
after uh right there
okay but you broke up with him like
right
but let me ask you since you're a giving
person and you don't have any problem
picking something up why
not on his birthday did you not make
those things special why is it i'm
asking you about his birthday and you
said we split a trip
because because if because if you're a
man and i asked what did you do for your
woman on her birthday and you said
you're this kind of man that kind of man
and i take care of everyone just like a
man said he split a ship would look like
a pure [ __ ]
fair worthy so why do you get to come in
here as an executive is that an
executive [ __ ]
it's a selfish personality which tends
to happen with only children
and what i'm saying ma'am is ultimately
if you you're a marketer you're in
communications and marketing if you're a
product what
product gains value with age and use
fair none right
man so you have to at least and if
you're going to sell an
older used product you have to be able
to understand its value proposition
what is your value to a man outside of
your your sweet spot or where you're
comfortable business what's your value
to a man outside of that
i asked you that and you said nothing
but word salad
i would say now if i had to answer the
question again i'm
i'm a supportive person i'm going to
help you build i'm going to be that
person that encourages you
that's what i do on my friendships you
can ask the girlfriend that's
encouraged me to join this tonight
a man worth i mean we don't need you to
help us build anything
okay the last guy you got with
you would disdain him because he wasn't
building
but see can you get a man that's
surpassing you
i would be completely fine with that no
no no i said can you get one i know
you'd be fine with it can you attract it
can i attract one that's a fair question
i honestly don't know the answer to that
i would say no considering my track
record of dating so far
this is why i say this is why i say
therapy is so important
in coaching because the reason i'm being
so direct with you is because it's the
only way you'll hear me
and you lack self-awareness you're used
to presenting and pitching and
convincing people
and the first person you've convinced is
you 37
wants no kids not a good 37 wants no
kids
only child selfish streak not a really a
good candidate for
wife for a man on his purpose
i don't feel like that's 100 fair
because you don't know my complete story
i don't okay and i'm not getting paid in
your complete story you want me to know
your story book a session
damn damn you can afford it
i don't know why you guys come saying
doing this [ __ ] when i say something you
don't like you it's not completely fair
how am i supposed to know but what i do
know doesn't sound too
you said it i can see that i can see
this i can see that i can see this
and now when i say something along this
lines well i don't know well
let's just judge based on outcomes how
many men of value or men that you
respect and admire are actively vetting
you to be their significant other
damn
[Music]
this is why i say uh we need therapy in
our community we lack self-awareness and
we
and we get to the point to where when we
have to have the truth total it's like
well it's a shock
oh she crying unfortunately
winter is coming people
my some of my critics gonna be like
that's so bad this is what happens when
you tell women lies
everything's gonna be good go out there
and get this go out there and get that
everybody wins
your best life do this do that don't
worry about the men
and then when men don't attach to you
don't keep you don't want you for
long-term relationships
then it's late 30s and it's like i'm
tired of living this single life i want
this one that
we've developed no relationship skills
you're still dating like
teenagers or 20-something and i'm sorry
ladies
it is time for you children of the
forest to understand where you're at and
do the work
it's not up to the men to be
understanding and walk the path with you
you would you want men who got on their
[ __ ] you need to get your [ __ ] together
to get to be with the kind of man you
say you deserve
i don't think anyone actually deserves
uh
a husband i think you have to earn a
husband and a lot of girls don't
want to do the work
um before you answer this question i
want to hear you define what an
alpha male is oh should i cut it too
soon
let me go ahead don't mute yourself
hello hello how are you i'm well how
about yourself
good how old are you i'm 24 years old
ah winter's coming you're 24.
yes sir what do you got for me
um okay so i did want to kind of give
you a quick background
um i am a college graduate i'm a teacher
and so my question for you today was
how can i attract an alpha male
okay well you said alpha male um
before you answer this question i want
to hear you define what an alpha male is
so when i think of an alpha male i think
of someone who is strong
confident leader
i also think of someone who is a
go-getter
and that's money just kind of quick
spill
what i think of okay
and
fair alpha male strong competent leader
go-getter
um anything else
i think of a pr of a provider as well
um i also think of someone that some
money
also knows how to treat women
someone that treats women nicely
that's not alpha males okay alpha males
take care of themselves
understood are you good with sharing
i would like to think so sharing your
man
oh sharing my man not quite
so you want a loyal alpha male who knows
how to treat women nicely
i do okay
and that's part of the problem you
ladies have been taught
to think in fanciful terms
a loyal alpha man that treats women
nicely
that's my dad
that's what i think of is the guy that
all these girls want
is literally my dad and i don't think
any of these girls would have picked him
when he was young
my dad is the ceo well was they sold the
business but ceo of a company
so clearly a leader that's like what he
cares about his company
and he's loyal like he's always been
like faithful
to my mom how many women want that man
and even when i asked my dad like i
asked him some of the questions that
kevin samuels talks about on his show
and for example i asked him the cheating
question and my dad
says that if someone cheats on you you
leave because they're going to do it
again and it's probably not the first
time
so it's interesting um hearing my dad
talk about this stuff but i think that
the culture
is a little bit different like in white
culture
um i don't even want to say white
culture but like
i think there's two types of rich people
right there's a rich people that went
through corporate america and that's how
they got their money
and then there's like the rich people
that built a business and sold it and
those are completely different types of
millionaires
they're highly sought after so right
what percentage out of one hundred
percent out of what percentage
of the single women what percentage of
single women want that man
a hundred percent okay
eighty percent want a man that's loyal
successful driven ambitious go-getter
knows how to treat a woman eighty
percent only what does the other twenty
percent want
that's a good question um
to be honest i think your number of 80
is very low but okay let's take it at
80.
okay 8 out of ten
eight hundred out of a thousand women
want him do you think he knows that
yes sir do you think the other women
know that
women like you want him as well
yes sir all right if eight if 80 out of
100 men wanted you
how likely do you think you would just
take one
when 80 are offering you provision and
this and that
how difficult do you think see it could
be hard for women to pick but women
crave
um a relationship
the ladies come in you want these you
want the tippy tippy tippy top
which most men aren't alpha males by
definition
are leaders they're less than about
three maybe seven percent
of the population what you really want
is you want
it sounds like you want a husband type
of man who's a provider
yes sir that's not necessarily
synonymous with alpha male
alpha males um
for the most part are wild and free they
have low tolerance
and they are quick to cut
women off
so let's read let's retract this let's
let's look at what is it that you want
as an outcome
do you want to be married in the future
i do want to be married with kids
do you want children with kids as well
how many kids would like to have
i would say two to three children
pick a number two or three
three how many kids do i want um
at least two probably not any more than
four
i think four would be cool but two is
five two all right
so uh were your mom and dad married
they were not okay how many children
does your mother have
my mother has two children two
yes sir by the same by the same man
different men all right do you have a
brother or a sister
i have sisters no brothers all right and
is your sister
younger or older all my sisters are
younger
how many sisters do you have i have
three sisters
um but two of my sisters are on my dad's
side
okay and how many
women did you have your father have
children with
including my mother too
so your mother had was reproducing two
people and your father reproduced with
two people
yes sir all right so you and your sister
are raised by your mother is your mother
in a relationship right now
my mother is married how long she being
married
she's probably been she's been married
for about three years
but when you grew when you guys were
growing up your mother was
in a committed relationship or was she
dating she was
dating but you could still say single
so what did she teach you about men
um me and my mother didn't really have
conversations about me
growing up honestly
so so so if you didn't have a
conversations about it it's fair to say
you weren't taught trained or anything
on how to deal with or treat a man
that is so true and i've been studying
up on your content a lot
lately and i think that's the thing i
like the most about kevin samuel's
content
is he makes it pretty clear like what
guys want and how they want to be
treated
and i don't know it's helpful i've
really been trying to learn and engulf
myself and
the man of a work in the world of a man
do
are you around any women who are outside
of your mother
who are married who are wives
yes okay my grandma
and my aunt are both married okay well i
guess what i should have made more sense
women who you're not related to
oh because one of the bigger tricks
is coming from a situation where your
mother and father weren't married
and you didn't we don't see
relationships
modeled when we grow up in a
single-parent household
so we look at pictures movies
trying to imagine what it's like but we
don't see what it looks like day to day
we see the pretty pictures but we don't
see the messy outcomes
so i can't tell you about that from a
woman's standpoint and that's
that's the problem with girls watching
disney movies growing up
i don't necessarily think disney is a
problem because
i do think you should be with someone
that treats you well
and i totally agree with that however
you also have to earn the person you're
with if you don't put in the work
one the marriage isn't gonna last and
two they're not gonna pick you
this is why it's so important for
younger women to get with older women
who've been there
and older women can teach them how to be
a wife
be with the man but that's what we've
lost in our community and if you want to
be a wife
you become a wife before you're found
you don't become a wife after you're
found yes sir
so um i can understand wanting
children and a provider but that gets
into a whole different segment and i'll
get into it
um what'd you go to college for i went
to college for
um elementary education i'm a first
grade teacher
alright so if you were married do you
want to have to work after you're
pregnant with your first child
no sir so
you want to have three children and you
want to be a stay-at-home mom
i still want to work after i birth
um our children so
what age would you go back to work after
your third child
maybe about three years old two three
okay but even if you stair-stepped your
children
that still would mean you're off for
about five to seven years
yes sir okay
that's really unreal that's 72 percent
of women
mothers in this country work full of
part-time
let me go ahead and dispel that notion
right there
you're going to work it's going to work
because that's what
72 percent of women in this country do
understood so i honestly
don't mind i mean
like that's fine i mean ideally i'll
probably have relatives help out a lot
like maybe i could pay
um one of my relatives just because i
think it's better to keep it in the
family if you can
but if i had to work i wouldn't care
that's in the best case scenario okay
you gotta i'll say look at the kind of
the lifestyle you wanna have
uh like the neighborhood environment
middle class whatever
and then also learning how to
actually cooperate or deal with a man
because videos are great but you're
going to actually need
knowledge transfer from other women
and you're still young enough to where
just like you went to college you got to
go to
school for this because unfortunately
you didn't learn it growing up
but i would say take your notion off the
term of alpha male
and this and that and and start worrying
about becoming a
quality woman and a woman who wants to
be a wife to a man
and know what you bring of value to a
man
outside of a bedroom yes sir
that's really because that's what that's
the one thing a lot of girls
think that just because they have sex
with a guy that they're all of the
sudden
more valuable and they should be chosen
but a guy can get sex from a prostitute
that doesn't
matter what men are looking for what
what is the best
long-term proposition in our community
we know how to do two things really well
have sex and fight
that's that's chaotic it's in its short
term what we don't know how to do
is coexist and that's what we need to
learn how to do better so
that's kind of why i took the long way
around it to take the whole alpha thing
out of there
i think what you're really looking for
is just uh
stable protector provider profit priest
kind of thing so
yes sir that's exactly what i'm all
right well that's then
then just remove alpha you don't need
that just say you look like okay
a solid man thorough man all right have
a good
okay um i'm gonna end that let me know
if there's another thing that you guys
want me to react to but
i love kevin samuels i think he's one of
the most um
authentic guys in the manosphere
um i'd say the small disagreements that
i have are more
on the cheating and the
i don't know i'm okay with working and
he seems to think that
women should strive to like be
housewives
like that's the most desired outcome um
which maybe it probably is statistically
but
i don't know i'm just i've been a hard
worker since i was so
young that i genuinely like would not
mind working
anyways let me know in the comments what
you guys think let me know if you
agree or you disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next
time